[Music]
hello beautiful people make sure you
sign up to patreon because we have our
excuse me doctor doctor here our first
doctor on the show we have an actual
doctor disproving all of Steve's
thoughts [ __ ] we have three other
videos with doctor dr. David here that
you guys can check out if you sign up to
our patreon and you'll also be getting
20 extra videos every single month that
don't get posted on YouTube so go over
there in the description links in the
check it out will Bart ever find out if
a woman has three holes or - okay but
today right now for this video we are
gonna be discussing how MDMA has been
used to treat PTSD do you know anything
about that consent is both of your
fields so my favorite chemicals your MD
and I've been done next to see in a long
time whoa what was that what it is can
be amazing
oh so recently the yeah what is it
the FDA has expanded access to research
so for researchers to use MDMA to treat
PTSD because they have found it ever
since like the mid 90s they've been here
and they're like being a little bit
lenient so researchers can be using
ecstasy MDMA to treat PTSD and they have
found that it's been very very helpful
for a lot of the participants so now
they do they use glow sticks - it's just
the doctors it is the combination of the
two yeah I know and music yeah the music
not bad just this is weird you can
activate you gotta hit but it can't be
too much because if somebody brings
sparkles out you [ __ ] go crazy yeah
react with the PDS yeah can you imagine
a doctor
with this now and watch me please the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies aka maps have
recently announced that they had
received expanded access like I said
approved from the Food and Drug
Administration I just hear him giggling
in my ear oh this is not why they I
think they invented the drug when
they're researching it was trying to
like help people be more empathetic and
in the 1660s right would you learn about
it there's a reason why it's been
because it's an addictive drug so it's
just like vicodin right fine vicodin
we're giving it as painkillers all you
get your wisdom teeth pulled out it is
illegal if it's not prescribed it has a
use I'm like I said I'm a surgeon so I'm
really anti pharmaceutical so you don't
do you have a prescription pad or do you
not get one as a sign I got a
prescription pad but I really try to my
mother so how much though
dude that shit's addicting this [ __ ] man
you don't it's all about the system
right because yeah you know conspiracy
corner but um Barmes pharmaceutical
companies we could probably cure AIDS
and cancer but it's more lucrative to
treat it because treatment makes money
not a prevention exactly and then so
your guys's philosophy as a surgeon is
to get the care Oh so some people leave
a little bit of cancer they just cut out
9000 that's malpractice
I see good at least I have some like
failsafe set in place cuz I'm like you
don't know what's happening when you're
under like you and it's easy like you
hope that they're doing with that book
like I've had asset Oscar feed twice
what is that
so Tosca is when I go up your urethra
four times yeah so I'm like I'm just
hoping well the first the last time I
was awake full but the first time like I
didn't know what they were doing I
didn't really understand it they did
give me a chance to really grasp the
magnitude
you know we're scoring a medical school
for years we're going to the presidency
for years we're not gonna screw it off
yeah but medical is still a science
right I mean we still I mean you still a
practice career assault right but it's a
practice like so there are no guarantees
and there's like no for sure way to like
that's too big something for everybody
because some people have like scissors
and tools in their stomach after
instruments Joe get in that was my field
I am sterilized surgical instruments
that's why I'm like okay
some people get a scalpel [ __ ] they let
they left them in the intestine does
that really happen how often does that
happen is that very very
every single instrument and the
circulating nurse needs to count every
single instrument and once it comes back
into the decontamination which is my
department we have to make sure all the
Austral even science I do breathing
techniques very nice dr. Dave when you
try to do like a towel when you don't
when you don't recommend pharmaceuticals
how come what's your what's your main
philosophy uh I'm a little bit Eastern
and Western it's more about preventative
maintenance so if you do the oil change
within a car you don't have to go to the
mechanic you get the engine replaced
because you never did a oil change
mm-hmm so always the stand for you don't
say [ __ ] but like also take it out
with a grain of salt sometimes there's a
predisposition towards genetic illnesses
like oh let's say oh there's a recall on
your car you did everything right but
there's still a recall on your car
thank you his kidneys always has a
recall my philosophy is take this with a
grain of salt you need to get merch
the world yeah dr. Dave take it with a
grain of salt
oh that's good though the world's
getting overpopulated there's a lot of
my specialty with molecular biology
which is mutations in the DNA so as you
have more and more sex and there's more
reproduction and there's so many people
DNA is gonna mutate hmm for you know
Darwinism right selective I forget what
it's called not just natural selection
we're not supposed to cure cancer we're
supposed to evolve it dumb out you're
supposed to let the people die but wear
a hat we have all these ways of healing
people now that I hope I don't lose my
medical license because Darwin is here
zooming out and looking at get the whole
you man so that's why I don't believe in
pharmacy yeah it's just cuz in reality
what should happen and naturally people
should pass away if you have these crazy
we're treating symptoms right we're not
treating the disease right let's kill
the virus because we want to show that
virus were humans
yeah we ain't gonna let you Punk us
around no flex - are you gonna rip that
I don't like how how long does evolution
take thousands of years millions of
years the human population is less than
1% of all of earth like why is it that a
flat in front of the pee hole that only
lives up when you reject Leto when you
pee in there closes back like an
old-school car with headlights like that
yeah butts all right so this is pee hole
right
and then that's something right here so
only when I need to jag light right or
peed because later it's fair wanna lick
the tip it's in the way no not made a
more convenient for the female it
doesn't have to be a big piece of skin
it could literally just be like a small
let me answer that question with another
question
uh-huh right what's the point of sex
it's it's to reproduce true so why are
there so many ants and termites in the
world how do they have sex there's like
one queen right mmm she just creates
millions of babies so she feed [ __ ]
everybody like that'd be dropping it
down in her I have no idea actually I
know but are you saying that we should
get rid of sex no no sex is pleasurable
for a reason yes so that humans can live
the next generation so you're saying
eventually we developed STDs because
that's supposed to weed out the other
people are not supposed to procreate I'm
not I'm not trying to be Hitler right
now but so but with lesson in purpose is
only what they do it for pleasure right
that's why Karl's were invented dolphins
that's a porpoise yeah you see the
inventor I thought you said like a dying
family yeah they need to invent a better
version of the condom I wanted to let
her know nothing dolphins need condoms
huh there was a guy that had sex with
her
dolphin what those a couple got exotic
land and then he fell in love with a
doll oh yeah we know well those are my
people they'll be careful those my
people the white people we try to veins
can we go back to this MDMA
yeah so did you study anything why are
Judy about this I learned about it but
honestly best treatment for PTSD is just
you have to talk to someone that you
trust with PTSD with we work with a lot
of veterans it's they don't trust anyone
and they keep having these reoccurring
nightmares so psychologically you have
to channel that energy into something
more productive and sometimes that's not
possible when they try to use drugs to
the biochemistry in your brain yep they
try to move it or get more dopamine oh I
get more of this you're freaking out too
much but I realize I have like as a
neurosurgeon I'm the brain doctor
psychologists and psychiatrists are not
no offense Joe um that's sister great
yeah exactly yeah but just a bachelor's
though I I study it he doesn't use it
from a philosophical point of view it's
like the reason that you're sad is not
it's because of something but you're
taking something to forget it
and just forgetting it is that a
permanent solution for the whole I mean
I believe in the conditioning yeah but
that's how a hospital Oklahoma Oklahoma
yeah okay my foods not spicy enough
let's just put more sriracha no offense
dude if you wanted to be a serial killer
he would be so [ __ ] good at
destroying us we put everything online
he even brought me this Vietnamese
coffee actually what you just said is
right because I do eat my food with
sriracha and also a grain of salt
order extra spicy he did it today I do
it's not enough it really depends on the
patient right
you have to like I told you guys in the
break like it it's personalized health
care there's not one cure for it just
take tylenol that was my mom solutions
everything
tick and Ursuline you're fine and then
Ambersons an antibiotic anything pending
insulins
anything ending insulin is an antenna
seven and then I actually got allergic
because she made me take it so much and
then I just went 12 years without taking
any medication at all and I was fine and
I became a doctor and I'm like hey don't
take the medication if you don't have to
buddy so are you telling me when you
order extra spicy food it comes out
extra spicy yeah okay cuz I deal with
the institutionalized racism of my white
skin meaning that when people see me
yeah they will not give me the extra
spicy they think I can't handle it and
they think I'm gonna I'm gonna ask for a
refund have you ever ate with Tim yeah I
have and it's not still not spicy [ __ ]
no because the real Aussie he little
[ __ ] how much alcohol you drink your
taste buds must be screwed oh no my my
taste buds are really good really really
good one point out has never stood for a
light I have good taste buds oh no I
just tasted them oh what a station taste
buds I did yeah what did things like but
so just it's just this is just my
opinion take it with a grain of salt
MDMA is not the cure for PTSD it's just
something that they're experimenting
with everyone needs a personal life but
it is the cure for boredom but they are
looking trying to improve it by 2021
oh [ __ ] for treatment it's secure for
the [ __ ] art they make cuz without
being on it I'm like this [ __ ] I'm not
telling everyone not to take any
medication at all follow what your
doctor tells you follow what your
pharmacist tells you and I'm telling you
it's a wonderful combination when you go
to a massive
[Music]